how incredible is it you know that the
salamander arm is being
rebuilt not with a dictator
it's kind of like the cellular automata
system all the individual workers are
doing their own thing
so where's that oh wait top down signal
that does the control coming from like
how can you find it yeah like why does
it stop growing how does it know the
shape how does it have memory of the
shape and how does it tell everybody to
be like whoa whoa slow down we're done
so the first thing to to think about I
think is that there are no examples
anywhere of of a central dictator
because in in this in this kind of
science because everything is made of
parts and so we we even though we we
feel as a unified Central sort of
intelligence and kind of point of of
cognition we are a bag of neurons right
we all intelligence is collective
intelligence there's this this is
important to kind of um think about
because a lot of people think okay
there's real intelligence like maybe and
then there's collective intelligence
which is the ants and flocks of birds
and you know termites and things like
that and and you know and and maybe it's
appropriate to think of them as a as a
as an individual and maybe it's an odd A
lot of people are skeptical about about
that and so on but you've got to realize
that we are not there's no such thing as
this like indivisible Diamond of
intelligence that's like this one
Central thing that's not made of parts
we are all made of parts and so if if
you believe that which I think is is
hard to uh to get around that that we in
fact have a centralized
um set of goals and preferences and we
plan and we do things and so on you are
already committed to the fact that a
collection of cells is able to do this
because we are a collection of cells
there's no getting around that in our
case what we do is we navigate the
three-dimensional world and we have
Behavior this is blowing my mind right
now because we are just a collection of
stuff oh yeah yeah so when I'm moving
this arm
I feel like I'm the central dictator of
that action but there's a lot of stuff
going on like every all all the cells
here are collaborating in some
interesting way they're getting signal
from the central nervous system well
even the central nervous system is is
misleadingly named because it isn't
really Central again it's it's what it's
just a bunch of cells I mean all of the
right there are no you there are no
singular indivisible intelligences
anywhere we are all every every example
that we've ever seen is is a collective
of some of something it's just that
we're used to it we're used to that you
know we're used to okay this thing is
kind of a single thing but it's really
not you zoom in you know what you see
you see a bunch of cells running around
and so is there some unifying I mean
we're just jumping around but that
something that you look as the the
biological signal versus the biochemical
the
um the chemistry the electricity
maybe the life isn't that
versus the cells
it's the uh there's there's an orchestra
playing and uh the resulting music is
the dictator that's not bad um Dennis
that's Dennis Nobles uh kind of view of
things he has two really good books
where he talks about this musical
analogy right so so I think that's
that's that's I like it um I like it is
it wrong though I don't think it's no I
don't think it's wrong
um I don't I don't think it's wrong I
think I think the important thing about
it is that we have to come to grips with
the fact that a true a a true proper uh
cognitive intelligence can still be made
of Parts those things are and in fact it
has to be and I I think it's a real
shame but I see this all the time when
you have uh when you have a collective
like this whether it be uh a group of
robots or a you know a collection of
cells or neurons or whatever as soon as
as soon as we gain some insight into how
it works right meaning that oh I see in
order to take this action here's the
information that got processed via this
chemical mechanism or whatever
immediately people say oh well then
that's not real cognition that's just
physics I think this is this is
fundamentally flawed because if you zoom
into anything what are you going to see
of course you're just going to see
physics what else could be underneath
right that's not going to be fairy dust
it's going to be physics and chemistry
but that doesn't take away from the
magic of the fact that there are certain
ways to arrange that physics and
chemistry and in particular the
bioelectricity which I like a lot uh to
give you an emergent uh Collective with
goals and preferences and memories and
anticipations that do not belong to any
of the subunits so I think what we're
getting into here and we can talk about
how how this happens during
embryogenesis and so on what we're
getting into is the origin of the set of
of a self yeah with a big with a capital
S so we ourselves there are many other
kinds of selves and we can tell some
really interesting stories about where
selves come from and how they become
Unified